I started to think about belief systems,
you know,
because you could say that each camp had its own belief system.
The one in the West was derived.
It had a very lengthy history derived from the Greeks and the Romans and Jews
and the Christians and,
and from various schools of philosophy and from the enlightenment and all of
that.
And then the Soviet Union was basically predicated on a rational philosophy that
that opposed the axioms that the West had evolved and each group organized their
societies around that.
And,
okay.
No,
I took political science for quite a long time.
Okay.
And the political scientists and the economists,
they basically thought that people competed over resources.
Um,
but that wasn't a very good answer as far as I was concerned because it wasn't
obvious to me why people valued the resources they value.
There was the economist,
just assume that there's resources that you value,
but you know,
people can value a lot of different things.
It's,
it's not exactly fixed.
I mean,
you tend to value food very highly if you're hungry,
obviously.
But you know,
there's lots of things that we value and that we want that seem somewhat
arbitrary.
Someone like a decision.
So I got more interested in why people valued things and what it meant to value
something and then what it meant to believe something.
And then how it could be that someone could believe something so deeply that
they would risk their own death to protect it or at least risk the death of
other people.
And maybe on a massive scale like man,
people are committed to their,
to their system.
Now,
you know,
a system of belief is not just a system of belief.
That's one of the things that I came to understand is that it's not appropriate
to make this too psychological.
People defend their belief systems,
but that's not exactly right.
You know,
we have a shared belief system.
Well it's sufficiently shared so that here we are,
we don't know each other.
We're a bunch of primates,
we're in this room and it's peaceful and no one's scared.
And that's pretty amazing.
And that means that we're all acting out our roles.
So we're acting out or roles.
And we have an expectation with regards to those roles and those two things
match and that's the important thing and we'll talk about that a lot.
It isn't the belief system or the integrity of the belief system even it's the
match between the belief system and the actions of the other people within the
belief system.
What you want to maintain is that match.
You want to act out your beliefs in the world and you want what you want to
happen.
That's good thing.
You get what you want and you validate your belief system.
Great,
perfect security,
but a lot of that is if we're interacting even right now,
there's a whole set of expectations that are governing what we're doing.
Like you don't want me to take your,
your little tablet there and smash it.
That would be shocking,
right?
You wouldn't know what the hell to do.
Right?
You'd be somewhere different if I did that and you would know where you were and
that's another thing to know because that's a fundamental difference.
There is a fundamental difference between knowing where you are and not knowing
where you are.
I think it's,
in some sense the fundamental difference.
You can think about it as the distinction between explored an unexplored
territory,
but you have to.